>> Tulsi: 30 YEARS AGO, RUSH
LIMBAUGH MADE AND INCITEFUL
PREDICTION WHERE OUR SOCIETY
WOULD END UP.
HERE IT IS.
>> I WEAR THESE RIBBONS.
CARE MORE OF YOU AND ANYTHING.
I WANT YOU SITTING AT HOME AND
YOU PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE LOOK
DOWN AT YOUR LAPEL RIGHT NOW.
DO THIS.
PUT THE CAMERA BACK ON ME.
WHEN YOU LOOK DOWN, WHAT DO YOU
SEE?
YOU DON'T SEE ANYTHING BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT WEARING ANY RIBBONS.
IT MEANS YOUR A BIGOT, YOU'RE A
RACIST AND IT MEANS YOU'RE A
SEXIST.
IT MEANS YOU'RE A HOME PHOBE AND
PROBABLY A WHITE GUY.
I'M NOT.
I'M WEARING THESE RIBBONS.
I CARE MORE THAN YOU.
>> Tulsi: ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I LEFT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
BECAUSE AS YOU CAN SEE, I WASN'T
WEARING THE RIBBONS.
I WAS CONDEMNED FOR NOT WEARING
ALL THE RIBBONS.
THE REALITY IS, EVEN IF YOU HAVE
1 ENOUGH OF 20 RIBBONS, IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THE LAST ONE, YOU'RE
DONE.
YOU'RE CANCELLED.
THERE'S NO END TO THIS INSANITY.
YOU CONTINUALLY HAVE TO PROVE
YOURSELF.
YOU HAVE TO BE AN ADVOCATE AND A
CHAMPION FOR THEIR CASE,
WHATEVER THE CAUSE OF THE DAY
MAY BE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DIVIDE US.
RACIALIZING EVERYTHING, STOKING
ANTI-WHITE RACISM AND ACTIVELY
WORKING TO UNDERMINE OUR
GOD-GIVEN FREEDOMS THAT ARE
ENSHRINED IN OUR CONSTITUTION.
RUSH LIMBAUGH'S PREDICTION FROM
30 YEA